trois vagues de chaleur 33 jours de
canicule des températures hors normes
l'été a été suffocant qui dit canicule
extrême dit augmentation bien sûr de la
consommation d'eau mais aussi
évaporation des cours d'eau et donc
menace sur notre eau potable et maziza
bonjour merci d'être là avec nous vous
êtes hydrologue et fondatrice et
présidente de Mayan cet été nous a dit
météo France a été le deuxième le plus
chaud après 2003 qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui sont sceptiques qui
disent que tout ça est assez
exceptionnel et que ça n'a pas forcément
se reproduire on leur dit quoi on leur
dit qu'il faut peut-être regarder les
années qui viennent de s'écouler et que
chaque année nous raconte une nouvelle
histoire de la France lorsqu'on regarde
l'empreinte cette année de la sécheresse
on voit que le Maroc est concerné
l'Espagne est concerné la Belgique 95%
du territoire de la Belgique a démarré
l'été avec une sécheresse extrêmement
sévère faut imaginer que en Belgique on
est dans un territoire humide
habituellement donc en fait il y a
quelque chose de nouveau qui se joue et
puis les territoires dans lesquels on
imaginer un impact potentiel du
changement climatique ne sont pas ceux
que l'on voit actuellement se mettre en
place par exemple la Bretagne regardons
les températures qui ont été atteints ou
encore la Grande-Bretagne cet été donc
on imaginait en fait que ce changement
climatique allait surtout concerné le
pourtour méditerranéen et on se rend
compte qu'on est absolument pas prêt
parce que toute la métropole est
concernée cette année on a tous les
éléments on a un hiver où on n'a pas de
recharge dans nos nappes phréatiques
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas cette
capacité de pouvoir tenir au printemps
et jusqu'à l'été avec des recharges qui
normalement arrivent l'hiver elles ne
sont pas arrivées et ça c'est vraiment
la première fois ensuite on cumule des
mois entiers sans pluie des températures
toujours hors normes regardons le mois
de mai c'était le mois de mai le plus
chaud jamais enregistré en France et là
on était encore avant le mois de juin
qui nous a annoncé une nouvelle canicule
et pourtant il y a eu des signes
avant-coureurs depuis quelques années
qu'on n'a pas voulu voir et en même
temps je me rappelle qu'en 2021 il a
énormément plu
alors 2021 est une année très
particulière parce qu'effectivement on a
eu ce que l'on appelle des phénomènes de
goûte froide ce sont des anomalies
météorologiques qui se positionnent en
général au large de l'Atlantique et qui
génère des pluies très importantes elles
ont généré des précipitations sur
l'ensemble de la France par contre en se
chargeant en eau ces basses couches
d'air ont été poussés en direction de
l'Allemagne et de la Belgique et donc
ont été à l'origine de la catastrophe
donc il faut comprendre que ce qui est
arrivé sur la France c'est surtout le
résultat d'un air froid qui essaye de se
positionner là où il peut et qui génère
à l'inverse des catastrophes extrêmes
qui vont dans l'autre sens mais si on
prend un tout petit peu plus de hauteur
on avait à ce moment là un dôme de
chaleur en Espagne des températures
caniculaires partout que ce soit le
Maroc des feux en Tunisie ymetrisables
on avait tout l'Italie et toute la
péninsule
ibérique qui était vraiment dans un état
extrême donc on voit qu'à un moment
donné rappelons-nous des images de la
Grèce d'Athènes en 2021 donc ça a été
malgré tout l'année la plus chaude
jamais enregistrée en Europe même si en
France on n'a pas été concerné il y a
avant et un après encore une fois ce
qu'on a vécu cet été
on sait pas où il faut être modeste
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne sait pas
de ce que l'on voit en tous les cas et
ce qui se dessine c'est une nouvelle
tendance une tendance ou chaque année il
y a des éléments nouveaux mais par
contre des températures toujours plus
chaudes et donc c'est sûr que si on
regarde ce qui se passe au dessus de nos
têtes on peut voir de la pluie et on
peut voir nos données une bulle d'air
froid et si on prend un tout petit peu
de hauteur on se rend bien compte qu'il
y a une quelque chose qui est en train
de se jouer qui nous dépasse qui est de
l'ordre de leur norme et qui surtout
arrive sur des territoires où on n'est
pas préparé en France on n'est pas prêt
parce que on est habitué à boire
beaucoup d'eau 512 milliards de mètres
cubes d'eau annuel et donc si on ne les
a plus on ne sait pas comment faire et
la nouveauté c'est effectivement que le
fait que plus aucune région française ne
soit à l'abri vous évoquée effectivement
la Bretagne Brest quasiment 40 degrés
voilà même la Normandie enfin je veux
dire exactement moi ce qui m'a
énormément marquée c'est en 2019 les
feux que l'on avait qui se déclarait
dans les champs en Picardie on n'est pas
prêt en termes de sécurité civile à
faire face justement à ces
déclenchements de feu parce que toute la
sécurité civile est à ce moment-là
durant l'été sur le pourtour
méditerranéen et sur l'accord donc ça
signifie qu'il va falloir beaucoup plus
de moyens de sécurité civile qui se
déploie sur l'ensemble du territoire et
surtout qu'on soit prêt partout même si
on ne sait pas où ça arrivera
majoritairement c'est un modèle pour
nous pour vous l'Espagne le Portugal
puisque eux-mêmes ont dû faire face
avant nous à ce mur
à cette canicule cette sécheresse et ce
manque d'eau quand on regarde
l'agriculture en Espagne je suis pas sûr
que ce soit un modèle au Maroc ont
surexploite massivement les nappes tout
comme en Espagne je crois qu'il faut
regarder ces exemples comme peut-être
des exemples que sur lesquels on ne
voudrait pas effectivement aller comme
une trajectoire tout comme la Californie
ou l'Australie on a j'ai envie de dire
maltraité le cycle de l'eau c'est à dire
qu'on a oublié un moment donné quelque
chose qui est essentiel c'est à quel
point il est il est important que cette
eau elle pénétrer dans les sols pour ça
il ne faut pas artificialiser nos sols
et lorsque l'on voit toute cette
bétonisation effectivement on se rend
compte du chantier qui reste devant nous
elle va finir par tomber ne serait-ce
parce que l'automne va arriver
la pluie ne nourrit pas bien la terre
parce que il y a trop de béton enfin
c'est il va arriver avec cette période
de ton âge c'est vraiment le fait qu'on
est des précipitations souvent
diluvienne
il y en a trop elle ruisselle dans un
premier temps et donc elle génère des
inondations souvent violentes notamment
sur les routes dans tous les axes où
l'eau essaie de s'infiltrer ensuite dans
un deuxième temps elle va effectivement
être absorbée par le territoire qui est
une véritable éponge qui a soif donc le
territoire est capable d'avaler des
millions et des millions de mètres cubes
d'eau et puis à un moment donné quand le
territoire se resaturne à nouveau et
bien on a les inondations
catastrophiques que l'on peut connaître
dans le pourtour méditerranéen donc j'ai
envie de dire que c'est la vers et le
revers d'une même médaille et donc
attention
à cette à se dérèglement du cycle de
l'eau qui génère le fait qu'on est soit
trop peu soit trop d'eau et donc il faut
effectivement retravailler
cet hiver oui et non parce que elles
seront rechargées uniquement dans les
zones où on aura des précipitations
c'est toutes les autres zones où il ne
pleut pas et bien la sécheresse va
continuer et il ne faut jamais oublier
qu'une nappe qui se tarit peut mettre
jusqu'à 10 ans avant de se renouveler et
de se rééquilibrer et comme chaque année
elle subit un nouveau une nouvelle
sécheresse elle a de plus en plus de mal
à trouver son équipe donc on va manquer
d'eau encore une fois c'est pas joie se
faire peur on va manquer d'eau je pense
beaucoup moins d'eau et qu'il va falloir
beaucoup mieux gérer l'eau c'est dire
regarder maintenant qui sont les les
véritables utilisateurs de l'eau décidé
ensemble de qui seront prioritaires dans
des phases de manque intense et surtout
décider de la trajectoire que l'on veut
de ce commun qui est l'eau et qui
appartient à tout le monde mais surtout
milieu naturel et on a tendance à
l'oublier
politiques peut-être à la clé pour
lutter contre ce qu'on appelle les
inégalités territoriales en matière
d’eau et de stress hydrique il faut ça
existe je sais pas s'il faut plus de
comment dire de solidarité entre les
territoires parce que il y a plus d'eau
à Paris que qu'ailleurs enfin oui entre
les régions entre les collectivités
alors effectivement on est absolument
pas tous égaux face à la question de
l'eau lorsqu'on habite sur le Bassin
parisien ou par exemple sur Nice on est
connecté à des nappes phréatiques qui
sont capables d'être résilientes durant
des décennies et qui pourrait vivre des
sécheresses durant des années et des
années sans pour autant impacter la
ressource en eau de ses habitants et à
10-15 kilomètres de là on peut avoir une
situation qui se transforme complètement
parce qu'on a un sous-sol qui est
différent et donc en réalité on peut
être complètement très vite déconnecté
d'une ressource en dos et ne plus avoir
d'eau dans son robinet alors que
d'autres au contraire vont en avoir
comment est-ce qu'on transporte cette
eau c'est des questions qu'il faut se
poser on est capable d'amener des
scanniositaires dans des petits villages
est-ce qu'on sera capable dans de très
grandes villes on doit se poser ces
questions maintenant parce que ça c'est
ce qui arrive devant nous donc voilà ce
sont des questions essentielles
effectivement moins utilisées d'eau à
notre échelle il existe énormément de
solutions mais il faut le mettre en
oeuvre de manière massive et on a
absolument pas le choix merci maziza
merci hydrologue et fondatrice et
présidente de Maya merci à vous et
[Musique]